my name is Sarah Davis on the sonicator
glass bowl both whisper straight you're
doing it for 20 years now young stuff
make all sorts of different types of
psychic glassware and other it's plaster
as well a lot of its bespoke that
theories a lot of standard stuff as well
the scientific supplies the lock
the glass is a lot harder than the
bottom glass as most people know that
she used to make bottles so it does take
high temperature to work and solidifies
a lot quicker as well designed to take a
lot temperature and chemicals especially
very chemically resistant glass and
pressure as well thanks back human
liquid nitrogen we make jurors for
liquid nitrogen traps tapes cold
temperature as well something like a
condenser simple condenser that's about
half now will be less to make from start
to finish
heating the glass shaping it how you
want to look and then you're actually
holding a bit of glass in each hand and
then joining it so you've got both hands
going so you need to with hand-eye
coordination as well and beyond that
both hands doing something at the right
time as well and then once we finish the
piece we put it into a kiln or annealing
oven and it's heated up to five hundred
sixty degrees and baked at that
temperature for half an hour forty
minutes that helps get rid of all the
stress in the glass and then it's just
allowed to cool down naturally if the
piece is finished
universities are big clients the
turnaround time for me to make something
from scratch
give me a lot
waiting to buy something in from
overseas which is where most of the
other stuff comes from that they use and
if they do break something I can repair
it for me usually so that saves them a
lot of time the money as well as that
people are getting older they're not
being replaced with younger trainees and
that's the universities are getting rid
of nickel I suppose I think the thing
that used to be the training ground for
up-and-coming glassblowers yeah that is
very much dwindling at the moment and
yeah it is very much a dying earth
you